[Music]
on this Friday night mounting questions
about safety in BC's back country in any
outdoor activity you can't eliminate 100
of the risk and new details about the
victims of this week's deadly Avalanche
the biggest storm of the season is
slamming into central Canada grounding
flights with a flurry of Travel warnings
painted into a corner police charge
eight people with art fraud for forging
works by a famous indigenous Painter
Plus a Nobel Peace Prize winner in
prison we are very disturbed at the
trial the reported crimes and calls for
his freedom
global national with Mara Nasser
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we're learning more tonight about
that deadly Avalanche in BC that killed
three people the victims were German
tourists on a heliskey tour their trip
meant to be a celebration for a member
of the group who just completed his
thesis he survived but the others in his
party including his father and
brother-in-law did not as Heather York's
West reports their deaths are raising
questions about tour operators and
safety in a deadly Avalanche season
it's the best of what a Canadian winter
getaway has to offer fresh snow the
promise of a day of fun on the slopes it
was to be a trip of a lifetime for a
group of four men from Germany
tragically only one of the four will be
making the return trip home the only
Survivor of this Avalanche is a 25 year
old man from eaging his father died in
the Avalanche she's 57 years old
and his brother-in-law who is 34 years
old also died in this Avalanche and the
third death is another 57 year old
member of the um of the council in Eagan
the Avalanche struck a group of 10
people in the BC back country on
Wednesday nine tourists and a guide on a
trip organized by the local tour
operator r.k haliskey the deaths the
second helusky tragedy in just over a
month a pair of American tourists were
also killed in an avalanche while on a
heliskey trip near Revelstoke BC nobody
goes out there expecting that to happen
and I think that needs to be recognized
right out of the gate but with a total
of 12 people dead in snow slides this
season the industry is facing questions
about safety hella and Cat Ski operators
are regulated by helicat Canada its 39
member companies guide 120
000 skiers every year every guest wears
a pack with a probe shovel and also has
a radio in any outdoor activity
you can't eliminate 100 of the risk
Avalanche Canada says this season has
been plagued by two deeply buried weak
layers across much of western Canada
making the snowpack very difficult to
manage safely the BC government says
it's in regular contact with Avalanche
Canada and could close parts of the back
country for safety reasons if warranted
we need people to seriously consider and
assess the terrain that they are going
into and potentially consider delaying
their trip until conditions are safer
for now though it's up to users to make
the decision for themselves to take a
risk for an adventure of a lifetime that
for 12 families so far this year has
ended with unimaginable loss Heather
York's West Global News Panorama BC
turning East now Ontario and Quebec are
also bracing for some dangerous
conditions a major snowstorm is set to
hammer both provinces starting tonight
with forecasts predicting the biggest
snowfall this year for the Toronto area
WestJet announcing this afternoon it's
being proactive canceling all flights to
and from Toronto's Pearson International
Airport those cancellations started at 8
pm eastern time and will last until
Saturday morning depending on conditions
Global News chief meteorologist Anthony
fernell has more on the weather picture
Anthony
Jeff this storm has a history of
producing some rather remarkable weather
from the beginning of the week all that
snow in BC then down into California
across the desert Southwest of the U.S
and then into the plains with severe
weather including tornadoes and now yes
it's Ontario it's Quebec and it's not
going to be rain or severe storms but
heavy wet snow that we're anticipating
as we get a little bit closer show you
the radar imagery there's still a lot of
rain a lot of lightning with this but it
is starting to transition now to snow
and it's just going to pick up an
intensity later this evening around
Toronto at times we could have snowfall
rates of five to eight centimeters every
single hour and with that rate it's very
difficult for snow plows to keep up so
highways are going to become treacherous
out there and it all pushes towards the
east impacting Kingston Ottawa and
Montreal are on the Northern Edge but
still snowfall warnings from Environment
Canada advising a 15 to 20 centimeters
the good news if there is any is that
it's March and it's a quick mover so
tomorrow it's back to some Sunny breaks
the temperature warms up and the Melt
begins but 28 centimeters forecasted for
Toronto a little bit less as you go east
this is also going to impact Southern
parts of Nova Scotia with a snowfall
warning for Yarmouth so a lot of weather
going on finally by late Saturday this
major winter storm will be headed out
into the Atlantic
Jeff all right Global News meteorologist
Anthony fernell thanks Anthony
Nova scotians were on edge this morning
after the RCMP issued an emergency alert
about a suspect considered armed and
dangerous 37-year-old Gregory Allen Barr
allegedly fired at another vehicle on a
highway in Colchester County and then
drove off RCMP eventually found and
arrested bar lifting the alert just
afternoon no one was injured and it's
unclear whether that attack was targeted
or random
at least seven people in Ontario are
facing multiple charges after a
month-long human trafficking
investigation that led to the rescue of
more than 60 people
the victims in this case
64 of them
were subject to deplorable living and
working conditions with no way out this
case has affected everyone profoundly
our members were shocked at the
conditions that the victims were living
in
police raided five properties last month
in the greater Toronto area the victims
are Mexican Nationals both men and women
allegedly found living in squalor police
say they were abused and exploited for
manual labor at farms factories and
warehouses in the region now at this
point investigators are not providing
the locations or company names citing an
ongoing investigation by the ministry of
labor
police in Ontario have also charged
eight people linked to an alleged art
fraud ring the group is suspected of
making and selling pieces under the name
Norvell Morrison a famous indigenous
artist officers seized more than a
thousand paintings and Prince all
believed to be fake as Eric Sorensen
reports some of the works sold for big
money to unsuspecting buyers
Norvell morriso's art is world renowned
the first indigenous artist in this
country whose distinctive style was
exhibited in contemporary Canadian
Galleries and remains beloved 15 years
after his death he's like I didn't paint
that
I didn't paint that but as a 2019
documentary explored his art also became
the target of fraud fake moriso artwork
now after a two and a half year
investigation Ontario Provincial Police
and Thunder Bay Police say they've
cracked a major forgery ring seizing
more than a thousand paintings and
prints eight Ontario residents five are
from Thunder Bay including a nephew of
Morrison have been charged these
contributions and his Global success may
have made him an easy target for fraud
what you see behind me today represents
examples of the types of work made under
and profited from norvel Morrison's name
police say one of those arrested David
Voss began making forgeries around 1996.
he forged some paintings himself before
growing his organization into a full
assembly line of painters some of the
alleged forgeries sold for tens of
thousands of dollars they not only made
fake art but fake certificates attesting
to authenticity John delandrea has
investigated art forgery's dating back
decades to the group of seven if is not
a new phenomenon so it's a it's a
function of of perception of value and
and an appetite in the marketplace it
was a terrible multi-faceted crime that
that has been going on for decades and
it's great that the police have
hopefully cut off some of its many heads
the morriso project researches and
promotes the importance of maurico's
work Carmen Robertson was pleased to
hear of the police arrests telling
Global News all efforts to ensure the
legacy of his art are welcomed and I
look forward to outcomes of this
investigation I realize what my purpose
is Mr breed nor Val Morrison's stature
has only grown with time the hope is
that maurico's original art and not the
criminal copies will be the Legacy that
endures Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
the Prime Minister faced fresh questions
today over those allegations of election
interference by Beijing a day after
opposition MPS voted to call for an
independent public inquiry the Prime
Minister reiterated his government's
ongoing efforts to confront the problem
but with the House of Commons set to
return next week the pressure on the
Liberals to take tougher action isn't
letting up our chief political
correspondent David Aiken reports
I absolutely hear that Canadians want to
be reassured
that independent experts are looking at
this issue prime minister Justin Trudeau
has not ruled out an inquiry but he
argued Friday his government is tackling
the issue by other means all of those
goals
are related to processes that are
ongoing as we speak
he pointed to the work of two all-party
parliamentary committees to work that
was done by independent civil servants
but none of those are set up to
investigate allegations of interference
with any party's nomination process
processes that are shielded by parties
themselves from public scrutiny and
that's where there could be a weakness
in Canada's system for example as Global
News first reported when liberal MP Han
dong sought the nomination in 2019 in
the Toronto area riding of Don Valley
North the Chinese Consulate in Toronto
is alleged to have sent two busloads of
Chinese Canadian seniors to vote for him
that allegation comes from a combination
of intelligence sources and thesis
documents dong and the Liberal Party of
Canada deny the allegations and say the
nomination rules were followed but for
the second time this week Trudeau
refused to speak to the allegations
about Dong but acknowledged Canadians of
some ethnic groups are more likely to be
targets of interfere than others we know
that Chinese Canadian parliamentarians
and Chinese Canadians in general are
targets greater targets for interference
by China than others Trudeau said Iran
and Russia like China also targets
Canadians who come from those countries
all the more reason the opposition says
to have a fully transparent public
inquiry Jeff David Aiken in Ottawa
thanks David
sentencing day in two high-profile court
cases
coming up the punishment for a Nobel
Peace Prize winner in Belarus
plus a disgraced American lawyer who
murdered his family learns his fate
[Music]
there's International outrage over the
fate of a human rights advocate in
Belarus who won a Nobel Peace Prize last
year Well Behind Bars alez bilyetsky has
been a pro-democracy activist for
decades he was arrested in 2021
following protests disputing the
election of authoritarian President
Alexander lukashenka now he's been
sentenced to 10 years in prison but as
Mike Armstrong explains Bill yaski's
plight has become a rallying cry for
opponents of the Belarusian government
foreign
by many as retribution Alice
billiatsky's years of political activism
earning him a political punishment the
60-year-old was sentenced Friday to 10
years in a maximum security penal colony
the offense smuggling cash into the
country to finance protests against the
government three other men also human
rights campaigners were hit with
sentences of 7 8 and 9 years U.N
officials are calling for the men to be
released as well as 1400 other political
prisoners in the country we're Gravely
concerned about the lack of fair trial
proceedings and access to an independent
Judiciary in Belarus
has fought for human rights in Belarus
since the 1980s he founded a Human
Rights group vyasana in 1996 and has
been a constant problem for the
country's President autocrat Alexander
lukashenka blyatsky was convicted of
similar Financial crimes in 2011 and
spent three years in prison
the latest arrest was in 2021 after Mass
protests against lukashenka's
re-election thousands took to the
streets while the Belarusian opposition
and Western countries called the results
a sham this is a Peace Prize was named
as one of the co-winners of the Nobel
Peace Prize in October while behind bars
he was praised for never giving up his
fight despite the personal hardship it
meant
now all three of the co-winners were
related to the ongoing war in Ukraine
one was a Russian Human Rights group the
other a Ukrainian group documenting war
crimes the yatsuki's selection was
called by some a slap in the face for
Putin because he's been a major critic
of lukashenkas the Russian Leader's
closest Ally the Belarusian opposition
leader now living in Exile called
Friday's proceedings a shameful mockery
and the men Heroes they represent the
protection of the individual's rights
against the repression of the state now
Canada joined a growing chorus
condemning the sentences the foreign
minister says Canada stands with the
people of Belarus and the men should be
released Mike Armstrong Global News
murder murders ahead the sentencing for
a once prominent and Powerful American
lawyer
welcome back in the U.S a disgraced
South Carolina lawyer will spend the
rest of his life behind bars for killing
his wife and youngest son Alex murdaugh
was found guilty on all counts last
night the verdict ends one of the most
watched and discussed criminal cases in
recent American history Jackson prosco
reports on the evidence that sealed his
fate
for the murder of Paul
Murdoch
whom you probably love so much
I sentenced you to prison
for murdering him
for the rest of your natural life Alex
murdaugh barely flinched as he was given
two consecutive life sentences for
murdering his son Paul and his wife
Maggie right up until the very end he
maintained he did not kill them I'm
innocent I would never
under any circumstances hurt my wife
Maggie and I would never under any
circumstances hurt my son Papa
in sentencing judge Clifton Newman was
unequivocal that he like the jury did
not believe murder after a trial in
which he admitted to lying repeatedly
meant when I lied I continue to lie and
the question is when will it end
when will it end guilty verdict Thursday
it took a jury less than three hours to
find him guilty on all counts Justice
was done today prosecutors say The
prominent South Carolina lawyer
embezzled millions of dollars and may
have carried out the murders to gain
sympathy and delay the investigation
into his wrongdoing
it was Murdoch's own testimony admitting
he had lied about being at the scene of
the murders that likely sealed his fate
prosecutors played this video recorded
by his son just before the murders where
Murdoch's voice can be heard everything
about me not going to the kennel was a
lie and you're able to just do that
that's so easily and so convincingly and
so naturally don't you
[Music]
judge the trial Drew International
attention for over a century the
murdochs were Law and Order and it
became the subject of a Netflix
docu-series luring in the public with a
sordid tale of murder involving a
prominent family and a legal Dynasty for
weeks the trial unfolded in the same
courtroom Murdoch's father grandfather
and great-grandfather all tried cases as
prosecutors
his lawyers say they'll appeal
immediately even if successful that
won't save Murdoch from a long legal
Reckoning he still faces nearly 100
charges relating to his alleged
Financial crimes Jackson prosco Global
News
[Music]
combating climate change next the fight
to preserve one of Canada's key
ecosystems
foreign
in the fight against climate change
Canada's peat lands play a key role
Canada's home to the world's largest
peatland carbon stock believed to store
some 150 billion tons of carbon but in
one region in Northern Ontario known as
the ring of fire that crucial storage
capacity could be at risk Krista Hesse
traveled to the edge of Hudson Bay where
new provincial mining goals have some
sounding the alarm
this is the world's second largest
intact peat land
stretching from Manitoba to Quebec
scientists are calling it Canada's
Amazon rainforest
and like the Amazon human activity
threatens its existence we do have to be
very careful about any decisions we make
about what happens in this region it is
a Global treasure that Canada is
responsible for
and the treasure is buried deep
underground
so this is sphagnum moss as the mask
grows it pushes down layers of
vegetation over time the dead plants
gradually build up and form peat and as
this matter is building up informing
this peatland it ends up storing a
massive amount of carbon and that's the
power of peatlands First Nations in
Northern Ontario refer to this carbon
sink by a different name in our language
the people call it mistake right that's
it's the muskeg it's the breathing lands
of Mother Earth billions of tons of
carbon will remain stored beneath the
surface unless it is Disturbed
drained or damaged peatlands release
large amounts of carbon dioxide and
methane into the atmosphere that carbon
is irrecoverable once it's lost to the
atmosphere we just cannot get it back
within our lifetimes and that matters
because a major mining development has
been proposed in the Hudson Bay lowlands
Ontario Premier Doug Ford has made
opening the region to mining a priority
in an effort to establish an electric
vehicle battery supply chain
we sat down with Ontario mines Minister
George Peary who supports the
development of the so-called ring of
fire so this project was once valued at
60 billion dollars do you have a current
valuation no I don't have a would you
say a current valuation but anecdotally
people are you know and and the mining
people are saying this is a trillion
dollar project
we contacted wailu Metals the Australian
mining company with the largest deposit
Holdings in the region to see what they
made of that figure a number like that
is
um is way exaggerated the ringify is a
special area but numbers like that are
are a little bit silly despite not
knowing the value of the minerals
underground Perry says the province
still wants to build the two billion
dollar Road Network that would connect
the mining area to existing highways but
there's concern the roads and the mines
if they go ahead could lead to unchecked
development turning a globally
significant carbon sink into a carbon
emitter Krista Hesse Global News
[Music]
and you can watch Krista's full report
on Canada's peat lands tomorrow night at
seven o'clock right here on global
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is from North Sydney Nova
Scotia we love seeing your Canada so
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you back here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]